c'est comme si elle était toujours là
toujours auprès de sa maman
partout dans la maison que larissa et
présente photos objets personnels
vêtements et même le képi qu'elle
portait lorsqu'elle a été assassiné un
jour elle est morte ce soap capitale a
toujours quand elle travaille alors
madonna souvenirs je grimpe
précieusement
avec tout ce qu'il ya de la vie au
travail pour mettre son chapeau le
bonnet c'est mon doudou m marie-louise à
nous amène dans la chambre d'enfance de
clarissa où elle conserve encore ses
tenues de policières dont celle qu'elle
portait le jour du drame
cinq ans après le décès de sa fille le
deuil est trop difficile à faire
précieusement tous et même des fois
dedans sourit aujourd'hui vient l'heure
du procès une étape de plus pour la
maman partagé entre douleur et
soulagement le 17 et le 18 septembre les
audiences seront consacrés à
l'assassinât de sa fille jeune policière
de 26 ans tuée à montrouge d'une balle
dans le dos dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions par amélie coulibaly sommes
intervenus en 2015 parce que la stcum si
je revis tout ce qui s'est passé en 2015
qui ont revoir maintenant puisque vu le
procès qui vous reparler de tout ce qui
s'est passé la dernière fois que marie
louise a vu clarissa c'était en
martinique durant les fêtes de fin
d'année quelques semaines plus tard elle
apprend brutalement le décès de sa fille
alors pour tenter de faire son deuil
elle veut des réponses ouah je veux ça
vaut presque s'est passé pourquoi les
gens ils ont ils tant de personnes
innocentes que les personnes n'avaient
rien à voir ou savoir les parents sont
en train de souffrir moi j'ai perdu ma
fille elle avait que 26 ans là je veux
savoir la vérité qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce que depuis 2000 qu'un jeu
dopage je suis tout le temps malade il
les oncles ont fait l'étude ne sont pas
là mais ils ont leurs complices moi je
demande au complexe ou pas ils ont fait
tant de l'étape du procès juste
permettrait de faire un deuil j'espère
que ça va me permettre de ferrandez
parce que là vraiment génie effet si ce
n'était pas ma famille je sais pas
comment je serai marie-louise à
jean-philippe va s'envoler mardi
direction paris pour assister au procès
témoigner à la barre
pour elle il faut que tout le monde
sache qui était clarissa